[Music]
cameras aren't working that's getting
super frustrating this is what it's like
on life below zero cameras are down
tough conditions all around a fill-in
no heat no power do anything won't even
turn on and falling too many times
yes Banton it's just a typical day of
the Arctic
they confessed what we got it's an
exciting time getting ready for our big
trip in the most remote location you can
think of Wow
cash is still standing this is just one
of our cycles in the earth the time to
come down here is now we're getting
ready to follow the hailstones out to
their hunting grounds and key wallach
we're here in Norfolk right now so
that's about 90 miles away by snow
machines so there's a lot of prep that
goes into getting ready for the journey
a lot of things up here when we're
filming in the winter start with digging
this comics trailer where we store our
gear here Norvik is pretty well drifted
in with snow hoping to get a dug out and
get one of our sleds out so I can load
it up start the packing process for our
big trip to Kowalik so we got the door
cleared out and hopefully it should be
enough clearance to open it up and get
the sled out of here
seems like we have a frozen lock that
happens from time to time I think some
water got into the mechanism of the lock
and froze just putting a little bit of
light or heat on it in the past has
worked pretty well for us the trick
alright here's a slit I was looking for
so this is our crew flat sled it's very
similar to a sled that the hailstones
use to move their gear around as well
pretty common in this area for moving
stuff in the winter time in addition to
keeping the crew safe and well fed my
role on the crew is taking care of
logistics so when we go out and do a
remote shoot it's my job to make sure we
have everything we need to set up a
little city that we can live and work
out of when we're out there
I can't run down to the corner store if
I forget something so I need to make
sure I've got everything that we need to
set up a comfortable little tent city
where we can live and eat and sleep and
work and enjoy ourselves as well out
there so this is something that we use
whenever we're working remotely it's a
big heavy-duty double wall canvas tent
it weighs a ton but it's really ready
for Arctic environment it can handle big
wind it's a good spot to set up all of
our camera equipment inside also to set
up a kitchen that's where the crew hangs
out and sleep so it's really important
that we have something good for tents
hailstones like to move around depending
on where the game is or what the story
is we're working on I need to also be
ready to set up mobile camping
situations heat is going to be really
important out there
I've got a couple different systems for
that very crucial part of our gear here
is this gas generator electricity is
very important when you're making
television obviously we have to charge
all of the camera batteries and keep all
of the other equipment functioning this
is our toilet we practice Leave No Trace
camping out there which means we want to
leave the Arctic environment just like
we found it or even better so we pack it
in and we pack it all out including our
human waste and I put a little foam seat
on there keep everyone's butt warm in 30
below I packed a lot of food ahead of
time when we're out spending a long day
filming and then coming back to camp
it's not always practical to make a big
dinner so I've prepared a lot of meals
ahead of time and frozen them and we'll
travel out with us and make the cooking
job a little bit easier once we get out
there so I've gone through the list I've
got all my essentials I'm gonna pack all
this stuff along with our personal gear
and all of our camera gear on our four
sleds and we're gonna head out for our
big journey to the Kowalik following the
hailstones we're Eagle crew out I think
this is our last year load
[Applause]
it's fascinating to watch the workings
of mother nature on this massive river
throughout the year when you live out
here
we don't have roads in Alaska most of
the rivers are there are the highways
and we live along an interstate our last
ride is with a helicopter so we're gonna
sling all of our stuff over to the bluff
16 miles downstream on the Yukon River
which is frozen right now hit it to camp
and film the ice break up this is all of
our supplies for the next two weeks
that's already two three hundred pounds
let's keep loading and wait for this
helicopter
500 pounds of gear ready to go
[Music]